rue et le banc langue russe et régis
laspalès
c'est le pauvre c'est nous
go c'est la première fois que je le vois
rigoler vous êtes malade le bon landru
sénart fois qu'on dit ça ça vous fait
drôle de venir ici sans maurice
chevalier
en tous les cas c'est une bonne idée de
casting je vous félicite parce que ça
avec la spada sans landry vous pensez
qu'un jour votre physique de sa vie qu
on peut dire que ce sera utile
allez enfin trouvé un rôle à sa mesure
oui oui j'espérais quand même que ça
allait arriver là voilà là ça il s'était
assez maintenant puisqu'on est dans les
serial killers on est sans nouvelle des
petits jeux ça fait quatre semaines que
petit j'ai ramé pas vu dans l'émission
alors quand laurent vous a demandé dit
quoi c'est vous qui voyez vous qui voyez
samassa m'a plu tout de suite j'ai tout
de suite vu ce que je pourrais en faire
c'est à dire raconter la vraie vie de
vendre mais amuser les gens avec main ce
qui n'a jamais été fait finalement ç'a
toujours été très noirs et là j'ai envie
quand même qu'on s'amuse il fait peur
dans cette haine melandru était comme ça
effectivement quand il m'arrive aux dés
avec ses maîtresses très sympa et puis
après bon c'est ce qui faisait un donc
laspalès et landru à marigny à partir du
1er décembre dans une mise en scène de
jean luc tardieu alors landru moi j'ai
appris ça en préparant cette émission en
1922 il avait 52 ans
incroyable il a été guillotiné cette
année-là beau cadeau c'est nous c'est le
premier serial-killer s'élève du premier
serial killer célèbre et c'est le
premier qui a fait rire aussi son procès
tourner un grand guignol on venait au
procès comme au spectacle voilà pourquoi
ça fait part l'été brillant exposé à des
démos d'esprit exact beaucoup d'humour
beaucoup de cynisme qui s'est entêté
devant la justice pendant toute la durée
du procès il n'a jamais avoué ses crimes
il est parti comme il dit avec son petit
bagage salir sans jamais dire si
vraiment il avait été se tord
qu'on l'accusait d'être c'était vraiment
lui parce que oui je pense qu a aucun
doute sur le fait que c'était vraiment
lui
ouais oui mais il a mille doute ouais il
écrit une lettre à l'avocat général la
veille de décapitation il a dit je meurs
l'âme innocenté tranquille j'espère que
la vôtre soit de même et pour que le mec
il est le premier barbu qu'a fait peur
ouais femmes
oui bah oui justement la pièce comment
peut il dire qu'il n'avait pas réussi
lui dans ses affaires
donc à un moment d'ailleurs un nom il
dit il dit la société ne fait rien pour
aider l'esprit de créativité des gens
honnêtes
d'après ces mêmes gens s'étonnent de
vous voir embarquer dans des entreprises
plus douteuses healing mais où
l'inventivité ya souvent beaucoup mieux
qu il avait eu plaisir femmes on peut
quand même précisé que d'après la
légende il avait un brâkmar je savais
que j'allais vous intéresser oui on se
demandait pourquoi excusez moi avec la
tête que vous avez landru oui il n'a pas
été conservé le brassard
non on n'a pas conservé bref c'est bien
mais je suis fière chez moi je vous jure
j'ai là je nagerai à chaud dit j'ai
acheté la vraie chaudière de landru elle
est chez moi la campagne c'est geneanet
bombay elle sera exposée dans le théâtre
ouais non mais c'est vrai que la pièce
commence comme un vaudeville et puis
après des situations extrêmement caucase
puis ça se termine dans le drame
évidemment mais il ya justement quand tu
demandes à sa visiteuse d'approcher le
sac de charbon de la chaudière c'est son
humour à lui quoi son côté oui s'ils
sont là c'est peut-être plutôt un peu le
mien parce que ça personne ne peut
savoir s'il fait ça vraiment l'ordre eu
ça c'est moi qui ai inventé la scène
mais c'est vrai que d'ailleurs comme
j'ai écrit la pièce il ya dix ans par un
je ne sais plus qui avait andré ou noyon
lapierre d'accord c'est que c'est
terrifiant quand la bonne femme
l'embrasser qu'elle lui disant vous ne
tuerez par exemple c'est ça c'est ça
c'est un truc est rigolo 6e j'imagine
que c'est vous c'est la veille de son
exécution il se rase il se coupe et il
doit l'être je le recommence le travail
c'est formidable